[Musica]
vorrei sera a bologna sono molto felice
di essere qua con voi questa sera è
felice di vedere così tante persone che
vogliano ascoltare capire meglio un
fenomeno antico come l'umanità è allo
stesso tempo un mega trend della nostra
epoca la migrazione
un fenomeno che è estremamente complesso
articolato e di cui si parla molto
spesso in maniera un po semplicistica
oggi voglio cercare di condurvi
attraverso alcuni aspetti che magari non
vengono trattati così frequentemente
io sono nato e cresciuto in italia
nonostante il mio nome e per 25 anni ho
vissuto nella stessa città la città di
torino e mio padre è nato e cresciuto in
inghilterra è venuto in italia da neo
laureato e poi ha conosciuto mia mamma
ed è mancato circa una decina d'anni fa
proprio in italia questo di introduzione
mi serve un po personale mi serve anche
per
descrivervi come la migrazione è
cambiata è cambiata nel tempo e cambia
nel tempo non è un fenomeno immutabile
pur restando appunto un fenomeno antico
come come l'umanità
la migrazione che ha e sperimentato mio
padre era un esperimento quella dei
nostri padri ei nostri nonni era un
fenomeno
unidirezionale un salto verso nuovi
orizzonti
un percorso un percorso di vita dove si
lasciavano dove si lasciano indietro le
proprie origini perché ovviamente al
tempo non esistevano i voli low cost e
neppure le chat o internet che
permettevano di alimentare nutrire
quelle quelle relazioni originarie della
propria della propria famiglia
io andavo spesso con mio padre e
soprattutto d'estate per alimentare
proprio queste queste relazioni e quella
parte di famiglia inglese lì ho imparato
ad apprezzare anche quello che era un
approccio un modo di vedere la vita e
anche la cucina inglese anche se mi
rendo conto che dire questo bologna è
vicino una bestemmia
detto questo oggi la migrazione sta
cambiando è cambiata oggi chi emigra in
italia chi viene in italia ma anche in
altri paesi
lo fa prevalentemente per poi tornare
indietro magari più ricco
intellettualmente o economicamente
questa si chiama migrazione circolare
dove le origini non sono perdute ma anzi
vengono molto spesso
valorizzate
quando sono rientrato in italia nel 2019
dopo più di venti anni di lavoro
all'estero mi sono ritrovato sorpreso e
disorientato perché ho trovato tanti
italiani dai tratti asiatici o africani
che parlavano con accenti emiliani
veneti
napoletani e questo mi aveva mi aveva
sorpreso positivamente
ovviamente tanti punti di riferimento
continuano a rimanere il cappuccino la
pizza agli spaghetti aglio olio ma anche
qui è cambiato qualcosa
il cameriere il barista il cuoco si
chiamano muhammad amin a carlos
ecco
quello che voglio dirvi oggi però non è
soltanto l'aspetto positivo della
migrazione la migrazione è un soggetto
molto polarizzante come voi avete potuto
vedere i politici e parte dell'economia
usano questo strumento per vederlo lo
vedono come un a volte come una minaccia
o un pericolo mentre altri in passato in
nome dei diritti lo difendevano anche a
spada tratta
ma avete notato che in questi ultimi
anni questa narrativa e non solo in
italia sta cambiando di migrazione si
parla sempre di meno e se se ne parla si
parla con quello stanco mantra di
dei numeri che salgono e scendono degli
arrivi delle emergenze tralasciando
magari quelle storie belle e tragiche
che stanno dietro dietro il percorso
migratorio
ho usato la parola fenomeno per definire
la migrazione perché la parola fenomeno
è un concetto neutro e la migrazione è
di per sé una può essere un problema o
se viene trascurata o se non viene
gestita ma può essere anche un enorme
risorse un'enorme opportunità se questo
viene
governata a livello locale a livello
nazionale ea livello internazionale
e diventa una situazione
diventa una situazione win win se nella
migrazione in questo fenomeno si
incontrano interessi e valori
vede proprio là dove si incontrano gli
interessi e valori che abbiamo
l'espressione più alta dello sviluppo
della della società umana e ed è proprio
lì che
abbiamo un un'opportunità enorme ma
molto spesso questa questo i politici e
larga parte dell'economia hanno visto
e l'inter e anno hanno focalizzato la
loro
il loro interesse nel perseguimento
degli interessi
l'interesse come espressione di priorità
economiche di sviluppo sociale e non c'è
nulla di male in questo ma la domanda è
si possono incontrare possano
incontrarsi valori e di interessi
possono non essere un
campo di scontro
secondo me sì e secondo me è auspicabile
che lo sia perché proprio attraverso
l'incontro attraverso rispetto dei
valori che si assicura la stabilità
democratica
e proprio attraverso
l'incontro tra interessi e valori che si
consolida quella piattaforma di civiltà
necessaria una convivenza di crescita e
pacifica
purtroppo sono pochi gli stati le
società che negli ultimi decenni hanno
cercato l'incontro tra interessi e
valori in nome della realpolitik del
pragmatismo si è preferita e si
preferisce la scorciatoia degli
interessi
tralasciando quelli che sono i valori ei
principi
svuotandoli quindi di potenza
oggigiorno documenti così importanti
come la dichiarazione universale dei
diritti dell'uomo risuonano quasi quasi
vuote quasi vuote perché sono state
svuotate proprio dalla primazia degli
interessi da quello che dalle a
concentrarsi sul mondo che c'è rispetto
al mondo che vogliamo
tutto questo preambolo lungo mi serviva
per introdurvi a raccontarvi la
migrazione racconta la migrazione
attraverso i numeri perché questa resta
appunto largamente innesco inesplorata
la forza propulsiva della migrazione
e quindi per metterle in contesto oggi
abbiamo nel mondo circa 272 milioni di
migranti
se li mettete tutti insieme e
costituirebbero la popolazione
dell'indonesia
oppure se è più facile visualizzarli
visualizzarlo sarebbe le popolazioni di
germania francia spagna italia e romania
messe insieme
quindi un numero molto importante di
persone che hanno scelto questo percorso
accanto queste persone però ci sono
anche persone che questo percorso non
l'hanno scelto e sono i rifugiati che si
attestano a circa 100 milioni di persone
oggigiorno
persone che fuggono da persecuzioni da
da guerre da da catastrofi ambientali
e in più oltre a questi ci sono pure gli
sfollati interni gli sfollati interni
che di persone che a causa di guerra a
causa di disastri naturali devono vivere
in altre parti del proprio paese oggi se
facciamo una conta su sette miliardi di
abitanti uno su sette è un migrante e
una persona che vive nel posto dove non
è nato o dove non resteremo
ma vediamo rapidamente anche quelli che
sono le
i paesi con più migranti perché questo
ci aiuta a metterle in prospettiva gli
stati uniti sono probabilmente di gran
lunga il paese
con un numero più alto di migranti
vedete nella scheda 49 milioni di
migranti ma quello è stato interessante
anche la terza colonna quella che ci
dice quale proporzione della
quale proporzione di migranti e fa parte
della popolazione complessiva quindi
negli stati uniti noi abbiamo il 15 per
cento di persone che sono migranti o che
sono nati all'estero in questa
classifica
una classifica abbastanza lunga io ne ho
scelto alcuni paesi in particolare e
concentrandoci un po sull'europa
abbiamo la germania come primo paese
europeo che conta con ben 15 milioni di
migranti con una proporzione del 18,5
per cento a seguire il regno unito con
una proporzione un pochino più bassa e
l'italia si attesta a circa il 10 per
cento della popolazione con circa 6
milioni e tre di migranti questo per
dirvi cosa perché queste società si sono
sviluppate anche grazie all'apporto
straniero della presenza straniera è
questo assolutamente importante ma
vogliamo fuori dall'europa andiamo verso
due paesi molto grossi come l'australia
il canada dove troviamo una proporzione
un numero assoluto inferiore di migranti
rispetto ai paesi europei ma troviamo
una proporzione molto più elevata del
ben il 30 e il 21 per cento
un caso a parte ma che volevo
assolutamente illustrarvi era quello
dell'arabia saudita con 11 milioni di
migranti e con una proporzione del 38
per cento di persone di migranti nel
rispetto alla popolazione ma attenzione
che questa non è una migrazione a lungo
termine o creatrice di innovazione e una
migrazione più a progetto stagionale che
contribuisce solamente a quello che lo
sviluppo locale e non mette in circolo
necessariamente delle idee un rapido
accenno lo vorrei fare sui sugli
emigranti un altro fenomeno di cui si
parla magari un po meno ma è un preso
punto tre paesi del dell'europa del
continente europeo per esemplificare lo
vedete per esempio che
ci sono dei numeri molto molto elevati e
l'italia si attesta con ben 33 milioni e
200 mila e 200 mila migranti all'estero
è un problema o un'opportunità di nuovo
è un fenomeno quindi dipende da come
viene gestito in molti casi può essere
una fuga di cervelli se non viene
gestito a solo beneficio del paese di
destinazione e non del paese di origine
laddove invece viene organizzato questa
questo diventa una risorsa anche per il
paese di origine per che circolano idee
circolano anche capitali che ritornano
nel paese di origine
rapidamente facendo ancora uno zoom
sull'italia quali sono i costi e
benefici della migrazione secondo le
statistiche nel 2020 la migrazione
contribuito al 95 per cento del pil
nazionale con punte dell 11 per cento in
regioni come la lombardia
a fronte di spese erogate dallo stato
per gestire il team servizi legati alla
migrazione di
25.5 miliardi di euro lo stato ha
ricavato un introito di 26,1 miliardi di
euro quindi un saldo nettamente positivo
un focus anche sul mondo lavorativo
quanto le risorse esterne possono
portare e migliorare i prodotti
nazionali un esempio vicino
geograficamente sicuramente il consorzio
del parmigiano reggiano che nel tempo ha
visto crescere tra le proprie fila la
presenza di casari e manodopera indiana
che ebbe provengono da una cultura di
trattamento delle vacche che ha permesso
di migliorare il prodotto finale un
prodotto quindi profondamente made in
italy migliorato da un apporto esterno
e poi parliamo di circolazione delle
idee del mondo accademico perché in
realtà sarebbe proprio la circolazione
delle idee che crea crea ricchezza e la
crescita della società dipende
fortemente dalla complessità delle
conoscenze
alcuni paesi hanno fatto di questo una
strategia per attirare studenti
stranieri nelle proprie università
l'italia forse un po meno ma questo è
proprio per non soltanto per far
quadrare i bilanci
delle università
ma è proprio per favorire la
circolazione delle idee e quindi anche
lo sviluppo
e in tutto questo come si pone lo yemen
l'organizzazione internazionale per le
migrazioni che io rappresento qua in
italia come agenzia delle nazioni unite
è certamente contando con personale
internazionale e di cultura provenienti
da culture diverse ma questa non è una
novità la diversità è uno dei valori
fondanti delle nazioni unite
l'innovazione che abbiamo portato nel
tempo è stata la presenza di mediatori
linguistici e culturali
mediatori e mediatrici
itc e culturali che lavorano al fianco
delle autorità in frontiera o negli
uffici immigrazione delle questure per
aiutare i nuovi arrivati a districarsi
meglio nella burocrazia ea e fornire
informazioni affidabili in modo da
diminuire la loro vulnerabilità e
permettere un accesso più rapido nel
sistema dell'integrazione
questi i mediatori e mediatrici
culturali poi lavorano con l'ispettorato
nazionale del lavoro nell'immersione di
un fenomeno come il caporalato
negli ultimi due anni i crimini contro
lo sfruttamento della persona del
caporalato sono aumentati notevolmente
proprio grazie alla presenza dei
mediatori culturali
e questo ha permesso anche di verificare
come
di smontare anche un
una percezione che questo fenomeno fosse
solamente legato a certe regioni
d'italia in realtà abbiamo scoperto che
quasi sistemicamente il caporalato
esiste anche in veneto anche in piemonte
in parte anche in emilia romagna
quindi infine il mediatore culturale
lavora con la guardia costiera la
guardia costiera per fornire quello che
è il
l'assistenza alle persone che vengono
soccorse in mare e per cercare di
identificare le vulnerabilità
all'interno delle persone che che
arrivano e metterle in protezione
penso per esempio le molte donne che
vengono da certi paesi africani e che
sono molto spesso vittime di vittime di
tratta
qual è la conclusione a cui voglio
arrivare in questo mio breve monologo
questa sera ea cui voglio condurvi che i
paesi che hanno saputo
favorire cercare le migliori condizioni
per
favorire gli scambi culturali gli scambi
di persone di beni di servizi di
capitale di informazione sono i paesi
che hanno saputo trarre i migliori
benefici da questa da questi scambi sono
i paesi che hanno fatto dell'apertura
alla contaminazione
un punto importante in modo da creare
innovazione sono i paesi che
attraverso questo hanno creato maggiore
resilienza in tempi di crisi e hanno
saputo anche creare meccanismi di
crescita strutturale indipendentemente
dal ciclo economico
ecco che qui troviamo non più lo scontro
tra l'interesse e il valore ma l'unione
tra le 23 le due tra i due punti
l'interesse che incontra il valore è
assolutamente importante un processo
personale ed è un processo collettivo e
su questo era una delle cose che mi
premeva anche sottolineare perché
laddove riusciamo a fare incontrare
l'interesse e il valore abbiamo
dimostriamo la capacità di crescere di
adattarci a quelle che sono le sfide e
le sfide globali
e cosa comporta comporta uscire da una
confort son da una confessione come
individui e come società le nostre
gerarchie mentali non sono più immobili
ma sono mobili e sono anche aperte al
nuovo come come non dato
ecco io penso che questo è il punto di
riflessione che volevo lasciarvi usciamo
dalla con forza per cercare nuovi
orizzonti e per creare delle società non
solo più giuste ma anche più eque grazie
[Applauso]